wenn sie armin laschet wie jüngst bei
anne will oder wie gestern bei den
kollegen von prosieben sehen wie oft
denken sie dann da sitzt der falsche
also abgesehen davon dass die beiden
sendung leider nicht ziehen könnte denke
ich das sowieso nicht wenn ja in der
zeit oder sich selbst nein nein
schauen sie wir beide haben wir da
öfters schon darüber geredet
es sind ja sozusagen der seelendoktor
der ganzen karriere pläne in deutschland
und machen sie auch ganz gut
ehrlicherweise und erarbeitet das jahr
beschlossen dass und konstantesten wir
haben
naja aber zumindest ganz nett schon ganz
nett und würde ihn auch gefallen die ich
glaube aber jetzt noch mal zurück zur
sache es gab eine kurze phase in der ich
versucht habe einen beitrag zu bringen
aber ein angebot gemacht und dieses
angebot stieß zum teil auf große
zustimmung zum teil wurde das dann
anders gewichtet und bewertet und damit
ist die entscheidung aber auch gefallen
bin
das kennen sie jetzt mich aber auch ganz
gut mittlerweile keiner der ständig im
gestern lebt sondern im morgen- und in
der tat ist es so was vorhin
angesprochen wurde
es wird für die union unabhängig von den
kandidaten eine große herausforderung
nach 16 jahren langen regierungshandelns
zu zeigen dass man nicht etwas schöpf 2
vom handeln so dass man über frische und
neue ideen verfügt und auch die innere
bereitschaft hat sich mit einer
veränderten welt auseinander zu setzen
auf neue herausforderungen braucht man
auch neue antworten
und es sind muss man im programm prozess
gehen sie sich genau dieser frage
stellen
ich bin dazu bereit wir haben in bayern
wenn ich das noch ergänzen darf in der
antwort
wir hatten so was auch mal eben 20 18
ich durfte ja kurzfristig vor der wahl
übernehmen hat ja lange gedauert und
dann haben wir auch im prinzip zunächst
mal das vorgeschlagen was man eigentlich
so normalerweise vorschlägt und ich habe
dann sehr stark gemerkt wie sich ein
land verändert durch digitalisierung
ökologisierung auf andere familien
rollenbildern all das was eigentlich
selbstverständlich ist und erst als wird
das akzeptiert und uns programmatisch so
ausgerichtet haben konnten am ende
erfolg sein weil sie das gerade sagen
wichtig ist nicht im gestern zu
verharren dass er das was sie den
anderen immer unterstellen
friedrich merz ist für sie total retro
der ist quasi aus den 90ern bei armin
laschet sagen sie auch immer wir wollen
ja nicht helmut kohl politik 2.0 und so
weiter warum modernes regierungsprogramm
das heißt für sie sind die ein gestern
und sie sind morgen und heute naja
schauen sie es gibt ja so den
grundlegende debatte und das merkt man
ja auch es ist ja in der csu nicht so
aber aber in der c doch
selbstverständlich nach so vielen jahren
da gibt's schon in einer anderen der
sagt und gut jetzt nach 16 jahren angela
merkel kommt man nicht mal wieder ad
fontes gehen also zu den zu den zehn
ursprungs bereichen zurück ich glaube
dass das bei uns weniger bringt ich
hatte auch mal so ein gefühl gehabt ich
habe von diesem jahr 2018 gesprochen in
dem glauben naja wir holen die afg
wieder zurück das sei nur ein paar für
konservativ
die wahrheit ist sind sehr viele echt
bös denkende menschen in vereinen
funktionären dabei die ein völlig
anderes weltbild haben und würden sie
die macht über unser land haben wird
eine schlimme zeiten droht und deswegen
ist einfach mal wichtig sich der analyse
zu stellen zb auch nach baden
württemberg in der wahl warum man dort
bei den jungen leuten bei den jungen
leuten auf dem level der fdp lag also
die union muss ich diesen anstrengenden
prozess egal wer vorne dran ständen
schlicht und einfach unterziehen
was ist die zukunft passen die antworten
auf die in zukunft wir sind wieder kommt
immer das schöne satz
man darf dem zeitgeist nicht
hinterherlaufen dem stimme ich
hundertprozentig zu wer hinterher läuft
ist beim fußball lieblings genauso der
verliert man muss den zeitgeist prägen
man muss zb klar machen dass klimaschutz
kein notwendiges oder lästiges übel ist
oder im gegenteil vielleicht von
vornherein denken dass wir eine
ökologische nachhaltige welt mit einem
wohlstands versprechen und arbeitsplätze
in verbindung gesetzt und es geht und es
geht gut und bei einem da habe ich
wirklich kritik bin ich so lese was herr
maßen alles so sagt das möchte
ausdrücklich sagen ich bin die vorwürfe
von frau neubauer die in einer anderen
sendung gemacht hat so nicht bestätigen
aber eines muss ich schon sagen wenn ich
manchmal so lesen wir über den staat
redet über das system rede zur system
vorwürfe machen die machen normalerweise
politische gruppen mit dem wir nichts zu
tun haben und da glaube ich bin ich
einfach skeptisch ob das uns allen gut
tut eine solche kandidatur
sie spielen auf ein zitat von maßen was
politiker aus uns machen wollen sind
untertanen die auf die 20 uhr
nachrichten schauen
um zu hören was die politische elite
entschieden hat wie werden sie mit mit
herrn maßen umgegangen als
kanzlerkandidaten natürlich entscheiden
delegierte vor ort er selbstständig
deswegen ist es sehr sehr schwer und ich
glaube im landesverband thüringen
das hat man gemerkt gibt es auch ein
sehr hohes selbstbewusstsein bei diesen
fragen
das konnte man schon der vergangenheit
sehen deswegen verstehe ich das auch
dass armin laschet ich kann diese
entscheidung nicht eingreifen
ich will nur mein unbehagen einfach
deutlich machen und das ist auch wichtig
dass man diese kandidatur einordnet und
dass man auch klar macht dass sie zwar
vielleicht als einzelperson da ist aber
diese nicht für eine strömung oder gar
die ganze union steht ich halte es auch
angesichts des themas dass sie von
valencia zu recht als mittelpunkt in
ihrer sendung bezeichnen halte ich es
für zentral wichtig dass die union noch
viel klarer als jeder andere sich
abgrenzt von sowas denn nur wer sich
abgrenzt auch von jeder form die nur den
verdacht gerät eine andere auffassung
interpretieren zu wollen nur wenn man
sich klar abgrenzt besitzt man auch die
klarheit und freiheit die dinge klar zu
definieren und zu position das heißt sie
sagen sie sprechen aus erfahrung weil
sie 2018 in bayern denn fehler gemacht
haben nach rechts zu blinken unter
anderem von asyl tourismus zu sprechen
usw usw
ja ganz genau das war etwas ich habe
damals dieses wort ist ja auch als
kenner der verwendet wurde von allen
möglichen leuten
ich habe damals das wort getätigt das
übrigens stand glaube ich von dem spd
land stand sogar mal in irgendeine
unterlagen jedenfalls handelt die
recherchen bei uns ergeben
aber es schien mir gar kein kein wort zu
sein in dem moment wurde ist in der
debatte war dass jemand anders verletzen
könnte oder falsch interpretiert werden
konnte und ich habe dann gemerkt und hab
mich übrigens nach wenigen tagen auch
bewusst dafür entschuldigt dass
zurückgenommen was übrigens mal sehr
wenig politiker tun wenn sie spüren dass
es jemand verletzt ist nicht nur im
politischen meinungskampf werden da da
ist manches auch ein bisschen wie soll
ich das sagen bewusst genommen ja das
sei übertrieben aber im politischen
meinungskampf ist das eine aber gefühle
wurden verletzt und es haben ja auch
leute gesagt aus dem kirchlichen milieu
die ich sehr schätze und dann habe ich
für mich gesagt es geht nicht ich habe
damals zu dem zeitpunkt ließ auch
gemerkt nach den ganzen aufmärschen der
der der der afg beispielsweise in
chemnitz denen sich noch einer
den ereignissen dort ist mir echt
bewusst geworden dass wir da an der
stelle nicht ein paar verirrte einsame
konservative haben die eine neue heimat
suchen sondern das ganz ganz anderes ist
und dass der leute sind die auf eine
politische bühne drängen die nicht vor
irgendwie vielleicht bei der union sich
einsam gefühlt haben sondern die ein
ganz anderes bewusstsein habe und
deswegen auch die abgrenzung deswegen
auch meine positionierung und mein
klarer kampf auch gegen die afd
seit jener zeit und ich denke auch in
bayern überzeugt dass das heißt weil sie
gerade sagten armin laschet hat es da
schwer weil die kollegen da in thüringen
haben hohe selbstbewusstsein
wir hatten friedrich merz auch zu dem
thema hinter sendung das waren ganz
schön ist ungeheuer also eine klare
distanzierung von jemandem wie herrn mas
ist völlig andere
er hat sogar sehr abdullah vorgeworfen
sie sollen sich gefälligst nicht in so
eine debatte einmischen das geht es dass
verbittet er sich das war das zitat von
friedrich merz
naja sie wissen ich halte mich gerne
raus aus der cdu das muss ja auch keine
anderen des intendanten der buddhist
will ich diesen fairen stil auch bei
beibehaltung ihrer sendung lasst mich
darauf mich verführen das mich doch ich
mich verführt jedenfalls bisher mit wenn
sie wenn sie diese diese tritte vors
schienbein immer wieder so ganz gezielt
setzen herr söder
warum machen sie das eigentlich sie
wissen das gar nicht was ich meine
welche triple fußball wenn sie zum
beispiel von kohl zwei blumen sprechen
wenn sie sagen die armin laschet ist
eine völlig andere generation als sich
klammer auf sie beide trend gerade mal
sechs jahre wenn sie sich ganz
ausführlich irgendwie bei leuten wie
peter altmaier reiner haselhoff bei
allen möglichen bedanken wenn sie sagen
dass cdu parteiprogrammen ist er so ein
flugzeugträger und die cdu wird so ein
paar kleine schnellboote mit so ein paar
mobilisierungs ideen dazu stellen sie
sich mobilisierungs ideen ich fand das
wirklich originell
das kenne ich aus der altenpflege waren
das lauter angebote die die cdu nicht
ablehnen kann so mafia mäßig oder was
war das man würde ich muss jetzt erst
mal darüber nachdenken was ich mir diese
frage eigentlich meinen gar nicht im
ganzen dinge von von pflege von pflege
und mafia ein flugzeugträger schlecht
zusammen bringen ich versuch's mal für
mich kurz zu sortieren das erste
wir sind eine eigenständige partei wir
versuchen
zu erbringen und es war ja so eine bitte
um verständnis wenn das so ist
ich war echt wirklich bewegt dass in
dieser bundestagsfraktion bremer
hamburger berliner die jetzt nicht so in
den beruf stehen seit jahrzehnten bayern
freunde oder csu freunde zu sein und wir
haben uns ja auch mal der vergangenheit
immer so einfach genommen wenn ich das
sagen darf und dann sich so also auch
leidenschaftlich für ihn einsetzen führt
es umgekehrt auch dazu dass ich da mich
bedankt habe und auch natürlich diesen
dank auch wiedergeben werde nämlich
beispielsweise jetzt auch bei reiner
haseloff wahlkampf mache ist doch
selbstverständlich wenn man gefragt wird
ob man helfen kann mache ich das war das
gesamte motiv hinzu kommt dass in der
programmdiskussion wir natürlich ein
gemeinschaftliches programm machen aber
noch einmal der lanz ich habe zum
beispiel bei mir auch in meiner csu
hatte debatte gehabt artenschutz wir
haben ein nach dem volksbegehren das war
eben einen auch parat wenn max lehmer
ich will ist beim klimaschutz genauso
weil ich davon überzeugt bin ich habe in
der csu diskutiert weiblicher und jünger
muss die partei sich aufstellen hat es
auch nicht alle geben die nur begeistert
waren logischerweise ist ja verständlich
trotzdem hat es zum beispiel bei den
kommunalwahlen bei solchen ausstellungen
und auch kandidatinnen und kandidaten
echte erfolge geben denken sie in
augsburg und nürnberg
also ich bin davon überzeugt von dem was
ich tue deswegen ist es kein tritt gegen
schienbein sondern es ist ein beitrag
erfolgreich die ausstellung zur amt und
armin laschet kann sich das sagen als
voller überzeugung wie auch die cdu
darauf verlassen dass wir alles tun um
gemeinsam erfolgreich zu sein wir wollen
allerdings nicht wir wollen keine
führung durch die grünen für unser land
das heißt wenn sie mit reiner haseloff
gemeinsam in sachsen-anhalt wahlkampf
machen resultiert daraus ja die frage
werden sie auch mit armin laschet
gemeinsam wahlkampf machen gemeinsam mit
armin laschet als verständlich machen
wir gemeinsam
ja selbstverständlich wir haben nicht am
donnerstag eine gemeinsame basis
konferenz die wir machen
bei diesen auch digital zu gestalten
also insofern sind zumindest mal auf dem
gemeinsamen bildschirm
aber natürlich wird es alle statt für
mich so selbstverständlich wir werden
auch plakate kleben wir werden in voll
unterstützen apropos bier ist auch
deswegen so lange nicht alle plakate
apropos plakate herr söder die kollegen
vom spiegel bericht aus einer hand
sitzung dass sie großen wert darauf
gelegt hätten dass auf diesen plakaten
nicht nur der kopf von armin drauf ist
sondern auch ihrer
zitat ende wie immer falsch zitiert also
ich habe ja von anfang an gesagt wir
plakatieren den spitzenkandidaten und
ich sage ihnen auch warum der alte satz
den es immer schon gegeben hat seit
allem auf den kanzler kommt es an
bestimmt am ende ziehen ja personen die
parteien und nicht umgekehrt oder ganz
durch dann sehen und das ist wichtig
unseren spitzenkandidaten zu
unterstützen und die nicht nur die
plattform zu geben sondern sich auch
darauf zu fokussieren
das in bayern es auch so ist dass
einzelne kandidaten sich wünschen dass
neben armin laschet auch der eigenen
partei vorsitzende mal kleiner vom
plakat komplett doch glaube ich
selbstverständlich und sie würden sich
jetzt auch nicht werden dann aber den
großen plakat großen plakate nee ich hab
ich wollte erst gar nicht das ist
tatsächlich so ich wollte das gar nicht
weil ich gesagt habe wir sollten auch
keinen falschen zungenschlag kommt weil
ich wusste ja schon dass sie an diesen
fragen arbeiten das internet dessen
erste mal sehen werden wir sind man muss
sich ja man muss sich ja da auch
entspannenden sie sehen ja zum beispiel
meiner tasse hier ist ein großer star
wars fan von yoda
ich versuche den rhythmus da auch gut
einzubringen also völlig entspannt zu
sein und alles dafür zu tun dass quasi
die guten gewinne natürlich aus unserer
sicht die anderen sehen das anders sind
natürlich wieder ist schon klar die
anderen glauben eher dass sie die dunkle
seite der macht sind und die frage ist
jetzt zum beispiel blick auf sachsen
anhalt eine kleine theorie die ich nicht
alleine habe das kursiert im moment als
wolfratshausen 2.0 szenario eine kleine
theorie armin laschet tritt an verliert
und sie sind deswegen so sehr für eine
begrenzung der amtszeit damit sie dann
acht jahre später selber antreten können
was halten sie davon
also irgendwann einmal sollten sie auch
solche strategien verschwörungs bücher
schreiben weil ich finde sie kommen
einmalig doch sehr interessante absehen
dies sei nicht allein also erstmal
glaube ich dass sachsen-anhalt gewonnen
wird
ja aber sie kommen als erstes braucht
also insofern ist schon so ja weiß nicht
wer von wem bleiben sich gegenseitig so
ein bisschen ab schreibt aber fakt ist
also sachsenhalle glaube ich wird
gewonnen
bei reiner haseloff ein echt starker
ministerpräsident sehr unterstützen
armin laschet
der kanzlerkandidat um die frage mal
vorwegzunehmen und ich gehe auch fest
davon aus dass wir im herbst die wahl
gewinnen können auf jeden fall die
nummer 1 sind und ich hoffe dann eine
stabile regierung bilden können so
anderes szenario für den fall dass
sachsen-anhalt anders als von ihm
prophezeit verloren geht schließen sie
aus dass die cdu noch einmal den
kanzlerkandidaten wechselt und
möglicherweise auf sie zurück kommt
das halte ich für völlig absurd
ein wenig frisch schließen sie aus
ständen sie bereit notfalls wenn es
richtig schlimm wird also wenn ich es
nicht wenn ich's nicht für das ist eine
so absurde frage ja nicht so absurde
frage wie kommt nie
und deswegen passiert sie auch nie und
deswegen völlig schauen sie nach einer
solchen debatte dann muss man alles tun
den kandidaten zu unterstützen außerdem
man darf armin laschet wirklich eines
nicht mehr dafür nicht unterschätzen hat
ein großes stehvermögen ein großes
kämpferherz und deshalb vorsitzender der
cdu geworden einem sehr langen nicht
einfach im wahlkampf der die zweite
auflage eines wahlkampfes war also ich
bin fest überzeugt er wird erfolgreich
sein und ich werde dann meinen beitrag
versuchen in bayern wo die deutschland
wo ich halt gefragt oder wo ich auf mich
einbringen kann zu bringen auch im
regierungsprogramm und danach sollten
wir eine regierung bilden muss man auch
schon natürlich mit mir rechnen weil ich
bin als csu-vorsitzender ja dann
möglicherweise ja teil der koalition so
ist es auch normal
und da freue ich mich auch darauf dass
das heißt das heißt sie könnten teil
dieser regierung werden oder was wollen
sie damit andeuten also ihren ihrem
verträumten bild im hintergrund nämlich
dass ihr platz offenbar doch wieder in
bayern ist aber offenbar ist das nicht
ganz korrekt jedoch also natürlich ist
klar dass ich ministerpräsident meine
aufgabe ist ministerin erfülle aber als
csu-vorsitzender sitz mehr im
koalitionsausschuss und wie sie wissen
bei aller bei einer notariellen
funktionalen aufgabe die eine
bundesregierung hat die wesentlichen
entscheidungen auch ein
koalitionsvertrag
zwischendrin werden im
koalitionsausschuss behandelt zwar in
der vergangenheit auch so und da bin ich
sehr gespannt wie die neue konstellation
ist was meiner sicht ist das so man muss
auch ein bisschen aufpassen mit den
prognosen also alle die jetzt von
schwarz gelb träumen müssen aufpassen
dass die fdp möglicherweise so viel
stimmen und leihstimmen von der union
holt das ist zwar zu einer ampel aber
nicht zu schwarz gelb passt deswegen
erwarte ich auch klar zu sagen
die union solle jetzt nicht darüber
reden mit wem sie am liebsten koaliert
sondern zunächst mal dafür sorgen so
stark wie möglich zu werden damit ohne
sie nicht regiert werden
sie reden ja dann sind wir dabei sie
reden ja am liebsten über schwarz grün
wenn die die frage kommt nach dem
klimaschutz wie wie substanziell ist
eigentlich das was bayern im klimaschutz
macht können sie das einmal erklären sie
haben es eben auch schon wieder mehrfach
angedeutet
ich höre von leuten die sagen es gibt
kaum ein bundesland das ein schwächeres
schlechteres klimaschutzgesetz und
programm hat als bayern
was sagen sie dazu es gibt kaum ein land
das einen niedrigeren co2 verbrauch hat
wie bayern
das ist die wahrheit und wir setzen
jetzt bei diesen klimaschutzmaßnahmen
eben auch wir haben schon in der
vergangenheit sehr viel getan
wir sind jetzt auch weiter wenn weiter
gehen als den wundervollen 2040
klimaneutral sein wollen übrigens eine
klima allianz machen
mit baden-württemberg mit winfried
kretschmann zumindest haben wir uns da
abgesprochen das bild im hintergrund ist
ja der bodensee was auch soziales
gemeinsame gewässer an der stelle ist
wir werden natürliche co2 speicher
massiv ausbauen
wälder moore unsere wasserstrategie wir
werden erneuerbare energien verstärken
schauen sie beispielsweise bei
photovoltaik dass unser hauptaspekt weil
bei uns immer die sonne scheint und
weniger der der wind durchs land pfeift
aufgrund der topographie machen wir mehr
als die grünen in bayern gefordert haben
ja tatsächlich so viele so attraktiv wie
in anderen teilen ja wie viele windräder
über davor an und wir investieren in pnv
zum beispiel ja indem wir 365 euro
tickets für die konzerte schon
eingeführt haben also da ist eine menge
unterwegs nicht wenn zwei dinge
interessieren wie viele windräder haben
sie im vergangenen jahr in bayern
aufgestellt neue windräder ganz wenige 7
weil die polaris bei uns das ist neu ist
jetzt so genannte zehnjährige ganz
wenige ganz wenig es gibt ganz wenige
jetzt in ebersberg haben die bürger
übrigens entschieden das ist
demokratisch das neue windräder
aufgestellt werden der landkreis in der
nähe von münchen
ein sehr schöner übrigens wir haben da
immer die klare regeln wenn die bürger
wollen ja
wenn die bürger nicht wollen dann sind
wir zurückhaltend war bei uns der
energetisch ertrag nicht zu groß ist
allerdings und das wissen sie auch ist
die windenergie seit längerer zeit in
deutschland ins stocken geraten
nicht nur in bayern sondern auch
anderswo regt sich nicht nur widerstand
werden kaum mehr windräder neu
aufgestellt deswegen kann auch die
zehnjährige nicht das eigentliche
problem seien bei uns ist einfach so
dass die topographie in bayern
und sie sind einfach mehr hügel ich
finde ich bis zu sagen darf die
topographie in bayern mehr perspektiven
bietet beispielsweise für wasser
geothermie aber vor allem für die
photovoltaik
da gehen wir sehr moderne ansätze die
wir da machen großanlagen biotop
solarparks häuserfassaden und so
ähnliches mehr
wir wollen eine pv pflicht auf dächern
beispielsweise banken das lohnt sich bei
uns deutlich mehr als wind alle letzte
fragen im zusammenhang herr söder sie
haben vor einigen jahren sehr laut sich
eingesetzt für 60 euro pro tonne co2 sie
und olaf scholz der jetzt das urteil zum
klima vom bundesverfassungsgericht so
cool fand wer das nannte waren dann
diejenigen die im koalitionsvertrag
dafür gesorgt haben dass es zehn euro
wurden statt 60 euro wie ist das zu
erklären
er hat das ganze system haben sie völlig
das system das wieder aufgestellt haben
war von anfang an zu starre ich habe
immer dafür plädiert und das könnte man
jetzt machen und dafür bin ich auch sehr
dass wir den co2 preis
marktwirtschaftlich entwickeln
ohne diese ganze deckeln frage also
dieses system marktwirtschaftlich
definieren sodass dann tatsächlich der
verbrauch bei co2 zu der belastung der
steuer für den grundpreis wird
umgekehrt brauchen wir dann aber
entlastungen in den leistungen müssen
zusehen dass wir für die unternehmen
entlastung haben bei der eeg-umlage und
den strom steuern also das was als
belastung da ist und wir müssen
überlegen wie wir den sozialen ausgleich
bringen denn wir müssen eine ökologische
marktwirtschaft auch als soziale
marktwirtschaft definieren und da müssen
über die instrumente noch reden
da glaube ich ist das letzte wort noch
nicht gesprochen und was ich alex hat am
schwierigsten findet bei uns in
deutschland
all die konzepte die wir derzeit
vorschlagen für dich sehr bin nämlich zu
überlegen wie können wir vom fliegen in
deutschland umsteigen auf die bahn
scheitern daran dass wir zwar war
ziemlich viel geld für die bahn aus
geben aber keine neue strecke fahren
können weil es 30 40 jahre dauert und
deswegen haben wir da noch eine menge an
beschleunigungs optionen die wir ziehen
müssen um ins gesamtes konzept
beispielsweise umstieg vom kurz flieger
auf die bahn zu ermöglichen